okay so we've talked about uh why it is
the importance of it let's talk about
how to increase it
well let's talk about what not to do
before we talk about increasing it
stop using shitty cheap products okay
that are designed to
mess with your endocrine system stop
using sunscreen that's not zinc-based
anything with
oxybenzone is what you want to stay away
from stay away from cheap toiletries and
soaps and shampoos if you want to
support the channel over my shoulder
here tactical soap is a great product
and it will not disrupt your endocrine
system here i'll throw that up on the
bottom just as a little
little uh push to that but anything
toiletry wise that's on the cheaper side
that has a load of ingredients that you
can't pronounce
stay away from it um dr anthony j
has on his website his recommendations
and these are all of his amazon links so
i'm going to send him some business here
and the j
there it is so let me grab the list here
and i'll throw it up on the screen so i
can talk to you very specifically about
all of them
uh what i use there it is so
share screen
so all you have to do is just google
search uh ajc
sorry ajconsultingcompany.com or just
search for anthony j dr anthony j
and then over here on this tab he's got
what i use
so if you want to stay away from
endocrine disruptors
um castile soap is very good it's uh
it's a natural soap you can click
through on his link it'll it'll take you
to an amazon link for
60 pack uh you want to use uh
hand soap that's unscented that doesn't
have any uh
phthalates that was the word that i was
looking for 20 minutes ago phthalates he
uses the word phthalates read the books
all the time
these things disrupt your endocrine
system also it's uh
red number 43. so if you guys are
drinking any
um sports drinks like um
mineral or sorry what are they called
vitamin waters or any of those other
like sports drinks where they have a red
color it's got a dye in it which is
called red number 40 and that dye
is estrogenic in your body nobody tells
guys you know these things they're just
like oh buy this because it looks like
it's good for you or it's got vitamins
in it or something they don't tell you
that it's gonna
mess with your endocrine system this
guy's done all the research pay
attention to it
all right so he's got the hand soaps in
there shampoos and conditioners again
you want to stay of
stay away from things with parabens and
phthalates
or an artificial fragrances all of these
things are estrogenic in the male body
they're going to mess with your
testosterone levels laundry detergents i
mean if you really want to go like
hardcore down there you know right down
the rabbit hole and go
absolutely like full [ __ ] on it um get
laundry detergents that
aren't gonna like put these chemicals
like phthalites and
oxybenzones and all these sorts of you
know preservatives
into your bed sheets and the clothing
that you're putting on your body
uh deodorant is another thing that he's
got a link to over here
diaper rash creams uh sunscreen so i've
used this sunscreen it's it's it doesn't
go on very easy like
i clicked this link and i ordered it i
thought okay cool you spray it on it's
gonna be on you know great it'll be just
like this i'll be honest with you it's a
pain in the ass
it is going to be more work for you guys
to manage your endocrine system and to
have a healthy strong testosterone level
than it is just
kind of go about it and and do what
society's always told you
to do um i always tell guys that i that
i crush
uh comforting lies with the
uncomfortable truth and the
uncomfortable truth is
for you to use a product like like this
for example it doesn't absorb into your
skin you're gonna look like casper the
ghost
right i remember there's there's this
one time one of the first times that i
used it
i was out on a rally and i had the r8
the top was down it was hot as [ __ ] out
i'm like all right i spray some of the
[ __ ] on my hands i put it on my head
i'm like okay guys let's go and
everybody's laughing at me i'm like what
the [ __ ] you guys laughing at
like you look like casper the ghost and
i looked in the mirror of the car and
yeah sure enough
the stuff does not absorb greatly into
your skin so
you've got to keep in mind when you when
you transition like when you shift over
and improve your lifestyle certain
things are going to change that you're
not
used to you're used to these things
absorbing into your skin you don't see
them well guess what you want to be
healthy you want to have strong
testosterone levels you want to be able
to reproduce and have healthy sperm and
all that sort of stuff
you got to take this [ __ ] seriously um
you want to stay away from perfumes and
colognes
completely okay a lot of guys will like
spray all their [ __ ] all over their body
and they think that you know women are
going to throw themselves out them
because they smell like
you know like better roses or whatever
honestly you don't need it you really
don't
uh he's got all the um stuff for shaving
creams
toothpaste blankets ink set ink set
repellents water bottles don't use
plastic water bottles either use steel
or glass ones
because the plastics uh do leak
estrogenics into the water
uh what else you have containers for
storing food like this guy goes
crazy right down everything i'm not
gonna go down the entire list like i
said you can go look for it yourself
it's got it all in there
let's go back here okay so how to
increase it so now that you've removed
things that are going to decrease it or
become estrogenic in your body
pick up heavy [ __ ] put it down have a
healthy diet
and get good sleep those are the main
things that's that's what our great
great great great great grandfathers did
to have testosterone levels that were
twice as high as what ours were
naturally at the same age
they were they were always moving around
picking up heavy [ __ ] putting it down
they ate natural food nothing with
preservatives
okay it's as simple as that and they
you know they slept well they didn't
have screens i'm sitting here at 8 38 at
night eastern standard time looking at a
screen
sending blue light at me i've got blue
light filters
on my um lenses you know they're coated
with that
uh but you know you mess with your
um circadian rhythm uh your body doesn't
want to go to sleep if it's got blue
light coming at it all night long so
shut off the lights pick up a book if
you want to pick up a great book and
read it before you go to bed boom
right small shout out there so
those are those are the big things uh
make sure that when you're sleeping
you're getting good quality sleep
a lot of people ask me about this ring
oh which did you get married
this is the hand you put the wedding
ring on by the way this is an aura ring
okay
um real quick let me see if i can get
that on the camera if you can see it can
you see those little bumps there
turn it that way on the inside right
there on the bottom there's like a
little circuit board and all that
okay that's those are three sensors
that are constantly monitoring and
collecting data and
what i do is i have this on airplane
mode all day
i put it in this little thing and it
charges and then it syncs to my phone
and it sends the data on my phone and it
tells me
how long i slept for whether it was rem
sleep deep sleep how many times i woke
up in the light
you know middle night which is probably
when i stopped breathing because i was
lying on my back or something like that
so
it gives you a lot of data to help
improve your sleep
and certain things that you have in your
diet that you can take out of your diet
when you your last meal i mean if you're
serious about living
a better life as a guy is an optimized
life i'd suggest grabbing one of these
aura rings i don't have a coupon code
they're not paying me to say this or
anything like that but uh o-u-r-a
i like the product it's you know
something that i've used for the last uh
i think i started in junish or so and
it's been a pretty interesting uh tool
um it's not the greatest for health
tracking like workouts
excuse me although it does do that
because the problem is when you're
grabbing bars
you know this you know this thing's on
the inside of your hand and you're
grabbing bars and stuff like that and
sometimes it gets in the way so it's a
bit of a pain in the ass but
it's a great sleep tracking tool sleep
is more important than you think right
that's when your testosterone levels
are pumped that's when you're pumping
out your growth hormones
you need to rest you need to rest your
body so that you can increase it
those are the main things and then
there's other supplements that you can
take um
i don't remember them all exactly so let
me go to the chapter in my book
i'll just tell you what the supplements
are
uh master violence why smart men avoid
marriage
i did i did videos on many of these own
topics too by the way
promiscuous primates i gotta cover that
one still
manage your f's endocrine system 103.
so vitamin d3 is not a vitamin it
like my endocrinologist basically calls
it a hormone
i mean a lot of guys are starting to
recognize that vitamin d is not a
vitamin
it's in fact a hormone that your body
needs and it plays a huge role in tons
of
uh functions within your body
the problem is is that most people are
vitamin d deficient in fact everybody
that's
that's been tested that i've seen
the reporting on
for covid has had low vitamin d levels
uh the government recommended levels i
think are like a thousand ius a day
maybe like 800 depending on where you
live which is like preposterously low
because
i have to take 10 000 iu a day for my
blood labs and i've got a stack of them
up there on my top shelf for my blood
labs to show that i've got healthy
vitamin d levels in my blood
um if you live north or south of the
tropics so the tropic of capricorn
tropic of cancer
you're probably not getting enough
vitamin d if you're dark skinned like if
you're black or if you're indian and you
live in canada for example you
definitely need to supplement with
vitamin d even if you're caucasian you
need to supplement supplement with
vitamin d like
my my genetic origin is again
mediterranean northwestern
european i need 10 000 iu a day just to
have healthy levels in my blood
that may not be what you need you should
you should
you should dose in accordance to what
your blood labs say
if you're not sure or you don't want to
pay for the expensive blood lab tests
you should be fine with four to five
thousand um another thing that you got
to know is that if you're taking vitamin
d
it's gonna it's gonna create
calcification in your arteries
you don't want that you get
calcification in your arteries you're
gonna get uh
you know heart issues you're going to
have blockages uh if you want to have
healthy sex life and you want your
johnson
and your tool working properly you don't
want calcification in
in any of your blood vessels so you have
to take a vitamin k
more specifically the mk7 variant um
along with so so for every 5000 iu you
want to take 200 micrograms of vitamin k
along with that because that moves the
calcium from your
arteries into your bones which is where
you want it take this [ __ ] seriously
uh what are the other supplements here
ah
emf that's another thing actually let's
talk about emf in a second
so we got vitamin d uh you want to
reduce body fat body fat
okay uh there's an enzyme in your body
fat
that is um which basically converts
testosterone to estrogen
uh it's called a aromatization
guys that are on heavy doses of
testosterone bodybuilders even some guys
on on trt that have really high doses of
trt
take an ai which is a aromatized
inhibitor which basically
stops or reduces the conversion of
testosterone to estrogen
the point of all of this is if you have
body fat especially belly fat
you have a lot more of that enzyme in
your body because that's where it hangs
out
so if you can reduce your belly fat
you're going to reduce your
conversion of testosterone to estrogen
okay it's going to keep you more
masculine so that's incredibly important
don't be a fat bastard remove processed
foods
i talked about the blue light part you
guys can read on that a little bit more
yourself
and i think the last thing i'm going to
cover is emf uh the other supplements
you want to make sure that you've got in
your system is definitely zinc and boron
zinc is critical uh with uh testosterone
production it's probably the most
important mineral
but a b c e uh zinc and boron are
probably um
zinc and boron will be the most
important and then electronic
sorry emf so electronic magnetic fields
you want to reduce those emf uh cell
phones
produce emf monitor lights
my computer this phone my wi-fi router
the bluetooth
all of the shit's bombarding our body
and that's one of the big reasons why we
have
this epidemic today we live in large
coastal cities
we get bombarded by emf from every angle
at all times
and it's very very difficult to get away
from it um
i've got my wi-fi on a timer you can
pick up a timer at home depot for like
10 15 bucks you plug your wi-fi router
into it shuts down the wi-fi i mean
if you want to be fastidious about this
and and take it seriously
that's just what you got to do um so i
have the wi-fi off
at night and then it comes back on in
the morning because i don't want i don't
need wi-fi signals going through
my body while i'm trying to sleep right
um another thing that a lot of people
don't know is
i don't have a cord here but i'll just
use a well
we'll just use like a water hose an
example so if you have a
squirt gun or a uh gun
you know at the end of your water hose
you use to water your plants and you've
got the water hose on there's no water
coming out of the hose
right it it basically stops over there
that's the way the electricity works
with your lamp at your bedside table
if you have a lamp at your bedside table
or a clock or your phone
sitting on that's not an airplane
airplane by your bedside table
there's emf coming off of the entire
wire going up to your lamp
all the way up to the bulb it's just
that little knob that you turn that
allows the electricity to go to the bulb
to power it up
that just brightens it up but there's
emf coming off all of that too
so when you start to look at all these
like macro details and you make all
these small tweaks along the way
you can have a positive effect on
managing your testosterone levels and
your endocrine system
again you want to be a man you want to
be strong and masculine
you want to have you know strong focus
and productivity
and you want to be looked upon by the
opposite sex and admired for being a
masculine man you need to have healthy
testosterone levels there's no
there's no two ways about it there is no
soy boy out there with the t
level of 100 that is having women throw
themselves at him
it's it's it's always chad you know
there's a reason why chad gets the girls
right
you